[Musik]
da hab ich mich setzen
warum heißt es eigentlich
verschwörungstheoretiker
also ich meine theoretiker das sind ja
leute die stelle these auf die sie dann
untermauern mit einer stichhaltigen
argumentation und empirischen daten
verschwörungstheoretiker ist ebenso ein
paar sky sagt einfach irgendwas das war
so quatsch sagen und sich dann als
theoretiker bezeichnen lassen ist so als
wenn man drei tomaten schneidet und alle
nenning koch also verschwörungs pascal
stellt einfach eine wacklige these den
raum zum beispiel bill gates will uns
alle impfen und irgend jemand traut sich
dann ihm zu sagen was geht so nicht
das ganz wackelig da haben wir ohne
pascal gemacht er versucht jetzt die
wackelige these von einer noch wackligen
halten zu lassen eher sache doch wegen
dem kinderpornoring hat pascal startet
jugend aufeinander
bis sie zusammenkrachen aber
zwischenzeitlich konnten staatlicher
turm dabei raus schneeballsysteme von
dubiosen firmen können paar jahre halten
pascals schneeballsystem hält nicht mal
ein paar minuten denn natürlich fragt
irgendwer irgendwann woher weißt du das
ja und dann sagt nämlich der
verschwörungs pascal informier dich mal
also er sagt ich habe keine argumente
aber wenn du willst kannst du mir welche
besorgen so als würde sich jemand zum
dass anni essen einladen und da
schneidet drei tomaten und sagt dann ja
ich bin übrigens koch gesagt nee die
tomaten sind noch keine lasagne und er
sagt man braucht doch selber ich wollte
nie dass hanni essen ich wollte nie über
eine verschwörung bescheid wissen also
mit dem verschwörungstheoretiker
sprechen ist immer eine einladung zu
einem sehr schlechten date an dem er am
ende selber kochen muss es ist eine
absolute lose lose situation
es sei denn du bist der verschwörung
stil des wegen fragt mich nicht warum
glauben dann alle leute an
verschwörungen
sondern ich frage mich warum nicht alle
daran glauben genau verschwörungs
märchen sind so eine geile vereinfachung
denn wir sind ja alle überfordert ich
zum beispiel frage mich warum ist erst
gut 30 jahre nach der mondlandung die
menschheit draufgekommen milchtüten
schraubverschlüsse einzubauen stand es
bei den wissenschaftlern auf der ganzen
welt immer zuletzt auf der to do liste
ja wir müssen noch zum mond fliegen
internet erfinden nachweis dass mit dem
milchtüten war super bowl das vorher
noch mal ein schaf clown ich weiß es
nicht
also ich bin ja nicht mal einer dieser
wissenschaftler und ständig überfordert
und dann ist es ja geil wenn du weißt
die milchtüte mit dem scheiß ausgießer
dessen erfindung der russen um den
westen zu demütigen
denn als die mitbekommen haben die
amerikaner fliegen zum mond haben die
sich in einem geheimlabor in sibirien
gedacht okay leute thema weltraum es
beerdigt wir stecken jetzt alles was wir
haben in die milchtüte männer bauen wir
die beste milchtüte die die welt je
gesehen hat wie otto dix kaffee das wird
eine lange russischen 8
ja ich glaube also ist jetzt eine
erfundene geschichte aber ich glaube das
waren jetzt nur männer ist jetzt zu
science fiction neunziger russland
weltraumforschung waren wenig frauen
dabei die geschichte ist er sowieso
quatsch aber ihr verglichen mit anderen
verschwörungstheorien grundsolide es
gibt ja zum beispiel in theorie bild
geht ist eigentlich ein echsen mensch
ist nicht echt wenn du eine
verschwörungstheorie glaubst du auch
endlich mal richtig über etwas
bescheiden du siehst christian rost und
links ihr mein gott er weiß immer so
gescheit
das würde ich auch und da kommst du nach
was er gemacht hat mega lange studiert
universitätsabschluss doktorarbeit
habilitation
ich kann nicht mal das wort aussprechen
dann merkst es extrem anstrengend
deswegen denkst du dir hier vielleicht
kürzlich das mit den 20 jahren intensiv
studium apropos mehr einfach 20 minuten
langen verschwörungs videos an und
danach rast und genau das gleiche gefühl
als wenn du wirklich ahnung hast und du
weißt die anderen das sind idioten
deswegen ist auch ganz wichtig dass
nicht wirklich alle an die theorie
glauben denn dann ist dein wissen ja gar
nicht mehr exklusiv also stell dir mal
vor so barack obama oder oder bilder
jetzt sagt jetzt in allen ernstes leute
ich bin ein echsen mensch er zieht den
anzug aus und darunter ist eine echse
das ist ja das schlimmste was dem
verschwörungs pascal passieren kann
denn auf einmal ist es mainstream wissen
dass bill gates eine echse ist ich würde
deswegen sagen jeder sucht sich ab
sofort eine verschwörungstheorie aus und
glaubt dollar
mega nervig für die verschwörungs leute
und dann wird silvia neid
doch wieder der erste sein der sich
denkt ich glaube was die tagesschau sagt
jetzt ist nur die frage welche
verschwörungstheorie passt zu ihm
[Musik]
einfach etwas nettes aus
genug von dem milchtüten neulich hat mir
ein kollege erzählt dass kein scheiß
das ist jetzt wirklich für jedes auto
das der heute-show youtube account
bekommt wird die cam trail dosis in
flugzeugen von der regierung gesenkt
kein wirklich gewarnt also weg er
schwört auf mal richtig richtig was also
wer wirklich gut finde da abonniert der
das ja auch an die kinder denkt und die
älteren leute danke